la justice encore avec peut-être une
piste cinq ans après la disparition de
la petite estelle mouzin suite à un
renseignement les policiers cherchent ce
soir encore les traces d'un corps
d'enfants dans les fondations d'un
restaurant en seine et marne et dix
personnes sont en garde à vue les
enquêteurs restaient très prudents et
discrets
lionel feierstein marie cazaux c'est
sans doute la première piste sérieuse
depuis la disparition d'estelle mouzin
mais elle est encore très fragile en fin
de matinée une dizaine d'enquêteurs du
srpj de versailles
entre dans ce restaurant chinois de brie
comte robert leur but vérifier les dires
d'un informateur en décembre dernier un
homme prend contact avec la police il
connaît les milieux chinois et entendu
une curieuse histoire celle de ce
restaurant un ancien local industriel
loué quelques mois auparavant par une
famille chinoise qui a engagé
d'importants travaux aient eu des
entreprises qui sont venues effacer ces
s'apprêtait selon pirates comme ça en
est content qu'ils ont passés d un ton
il ya quand même un mur complet ici qui
a été coupée n'ont pas cédé faire donc
cccp du trail c'est en garde à vue un
ouvrier chinois a avoué avoir découvert
en juillet dernier lors du creusement
d'une dalle les ossements sont savoir
dit il si c'étaient ceux d'un humain à
l'époque les restaurateurs n'ont rien
dit il se serait débarrassé de ses
ossements dans une benne à ordures les
policiers cherchent à savoir s'il en
reste d'autres sous la dalle
l'informateur de la police lui
préciserait qu'il s'agit d'une petite
fille aux cheveux longs
à côté de laquelle se trouvait un
morceau de tissu rouge
information non confirmée ce soir par
les gardés-à-vue la petite estelle
enlevés le 9 janvier 2003 à guermantes
portait précisément un petit pull rouge
brie-comte-robert se trouve à 27 km pour
les enquêteurs tous ces éléments
constituent encore une simple hypothèse
mais une hypothèse crédible
c'est une piste extrêmement sérieuse les
moyens sont mis
et tous les toutes les recherches ont
fait ça paraît en tout cas de nature à
démontrer que des faits criminels ont
été commis ce soir une dizaine de
personnes est toujours en garde à vue
les fouilles elle ne donne rien pour
l'instant elle devrait se prolonger
toute la soirée